Jew number one here we go oh hi there
I'm aria with a quick investigation into
the vast challenge that is sweeping the
internet right now well there is a new
viral trend that will put your sneakers
to the test someone posted on Twitter
that no matter how you throw them
they'll always land right-side up
the van's challenge posits that
apparently when you throw a pair of ads
to the air it'll often land upright even
on their side they'll flip right back on
up even our team over to New York have
taken a stab at it what's up guys were
in the New York office and today we're
gonna be testing to see if vans always
land right-side up and we've got a
pretty long stairwell here we've got a
dirty old van shoe number one here we go
Eric watch out shoe number two coming
down little flip action risking my life
oh my god but to see how accurate this
challenge actually is we conducted an
experiment here on site and we'll just
cut to that footage right now hi I'm
Yvonne and we're out here ready to flip
our vans three times and we're gonna see
how often they'll end up right go Megan
[Music]
all right we're training in a second
time we're getting a little flashy this
time
[Music]
all right we're gonna try it one more
time seating down and we're gonna drop
them with the soleus up almost only two
didn't work all right so it seems like
most of the time it landed sometimes it
didn't but I feel like it's just about
the way you threw the shoe the science
in the soles the weight distribution
makes the science make them land flat
and that's why I think it lands upright
because this is just it's so heavy
the bottom is super heavy that always
just wants to fall on that also it's a
skate shoe you know when you're
shredding the gnar you want to be able
to land on your feet skate for life but
of course they're not actual scientists
so I reached out to a real physicist to
get his thoughts of what could possibly
be the scientific explanation for this
mini phenomenon taking place first of
all a number of comments that people see
the reason to help us is because the
soles of the shoes are really heavy and
the tops are really light but in reality
that's not the key so I have a little
prop here I have a little hammer and
we're all used to the idea that if you
grab it by the end of the handle it will
just fall down like this and so you
might think that therefore it will try
to fly around like this as well that's
actually not the case because when it's
it flying it's not being held bites and
in reality things tend to rotate about
what we call the center of mass where
they are completely free to orient
themselves in you which way and the
result is that when the thing is flying
around it's tumbling completely
uniformly and it's just as likely to hit
the floor with a heavy part up as with a
life-partner
when I looked at the videos what I
noticed is that people report the shoes
not the moment they hit the floor but
after they leave the floor they
on the floor and that people look at how
they ended up my suspicion is that
what's going on is there is a preference
for them to a land with the laces up
because of your weight their roll on the
floor not because of the way they fly
around on the air and there can be a
couple of reasons
first of all when they roll around on
the floor this souls rubber and they
have more friction and so as they shoot
tumbles out of the floor it's just more
likely to catch on the rubbery stick
your shoe that on the most slippery top
and that will make it more likely to
stop the other part is when the shoe
rolls around and finds itself standing
on edge then it has accounts of fall
into the right foot to the left and as
we all know things will tend to topple
over towards the hairy part but again
it's none of the weights flying around
in the air it's from the way that it
rolls around on the floor so they
friction of the robbery soul and the
propensity of something to fall down
into the heavier direction while
standing on edge I think what might be
behind this observation if we truly is
something happens we have so there you
have it it's not a hundred percent I
guarantee that the shoe will always land
upright when you throw it what's a fun
little challenge and if you have an
enclosed space in which you can chuck
your bans in the air please feel free to
do so
and let us know down in the comments how
how that turned out for you until then
I'm gonna finish this Greek yogurt oh my
god oh that's not funny
15 grams of protein though